andrew cuomo is as defiant as ever the
new york government
is refusing again to apologize for his
growing nursing home scandal
instead cuomo is blaming the controversy
on lies and misinformation
watch this we created the void
by not producing enough public
information quickly enough i get that
but then it was exploited with
misinformation
people playing politics republicans
playing politics
personal attacks personal agendas no one
has a right
to spread lies or misinformation that
causes
pain to families it is a lie
to say any numbers were inaccurate
that is a lie while cuomo pretends that
he
the what he did is just some conspiracy
theory
the walls are closing in on him new york
republicans are starting the process to
impeach the governor
and a new watchdog report says cuomo's
nursing home policy
may have led to over 1 000 deaths
i'll go to you jesse uh the the
the governor being defiant and saying
basically
i didn't push back hard enough i didn't
produce enough public information
fast enough do you buy that
yeah that's like yeah he says uh yeah we
just uh
created a void of information really
imagine if trump told mueller to stuff
it and wasn't turning over documents and
said i'm just creating a void
of information judge i'm not going to
pay my taxes this year and i'm just
going to tell the irs
i'm just creating a void of taxes i mean
who gets away with a lie like that
and then he says oh yeah we never
were inaccurate on the nursing home
fatality numbers
i mean as of last week we found out
yeah i mean at least he didn't go to
cancun
this guy's out of his mind i i read this
thing i'm sure
dana read it she's not here today it was
in the washington post
by mark thiessen i don't know how to
pronounce his name i think it's mark
thiessen and he said it's not just that
you're obstructing a federal
investigation
it's that in march and april he was
obstructing
in real time information to be given to
scientists
and federal health officials who needed
to be learning about the virus the
mutation
right the spread where it was happening
who was it going to and they weren't
able to get access to that and he said
great analogy and i'm the king of
analogies he said this is like providing
false intelligence to battlefield
commanders about the location
of the enemy in a time of war and now
it's gotten so bad
aoc is calling for an investigation so
you know cuomo's in deep doodoo
well you know at the very least uh a
juan
shouldn't there be a removal of the
emergency pandemic powers that the
governor has until this is sorted out
by the fbi by the brooklyn united states
attorney's office and the
leticia james is attorney general's
office
well i don't know exactly what the
powers are judge but i i
think that what you're going to see is a
very thorough investigation i think you
notice
so many democrats are highly critical
yeah so the democrats are highly
critical including leticia james the
attorney general who has
ambition to become governor herself so
you can imagine that's going to be
pretty aggressive
uh investigation down there questioning
are you
questioning her numbers saying he
counted by okay go ahead
no i think and i mean his best defense
is that the total numbers
are not wrong but i don't think there's
any question
from all that i've seen that the number
to the nursing homes were not right and
he should apologize for that he should
specifically apologize to families that
were impacted by this
but i i just think that you've got to
understand the nature
i'm sorry yeah why don't we go to greg
because we don't have a lot of time here
greg is an apology at this point enough
once his own party is calling him out
seeking to
impeach him seeking to remove his
emergency powers and the feds
as well as the state are on him
i think he i think you you needed
investigation i don't think an apology
is enough i mean
the magic word obviously today was void
the problem is it worked because now you
realize he is avoiding
responsibility and he's as juan points
out
he's playing kind of a game with the
argument about total numbers
we're past that no one's accusing him of
fudging total numbers
it's the attribution of the of where
covid came from which is rest homes
versus dying in the hospital
and when he's talking about information
you have to remember he was at the top
of the information
chain it was you know who can forget his
daily briefings
how everybody lauded how wonderful they
were and so he was taking credit for
these daily briefings when the
information
was wrong and then suddenly the
information became real and
right and now he's blaming an amorphous
villain lastly uh judge i
i there's something that does bug me de
blasio is gaining political cover from
this
uh because cuomo's story is so cuomo's
screw-up is so
such a huge national story that it gives
de blasio the worst mayor in history
uh a free pass for his own destructive
incompetence yeah yeah
but but but greg not for that long he'll
mess up immediately
jillian in the last question to you well
you know uh he said
you know if you lie you know i and it's
inaccurate you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
hold you to it which kind of folds right
into his threats
to assemblymen and his dismissal of our
janisteen
um you know this guy is clearly a bully
how is this going to end for him
well i think there's going to be if
nothing else there will be political
consequences here judge by my count he's
now facing the potential for
an official impeachment proceeding he's
facing the possibility of losing his
emergency authority powers which
essentially means that as governor he
can't help
lead policy decision making during
national crises in his state
the third thing that he's facing here is
voters when he's next up for reelection
we'll see how they react here but a
quick note on part of why the void of
information
itself was such a problem is because
remember
that the state of new york the city of
new york
was what ceded this virus spreading
across the rest of the nation it's not
like the cuomo policies just
impacted people at nursing homes in new
york state
what happened there spread across the
red of the rest of the country over the
ensuing months and really helped see the
virus spread
all across the nation for millions of
americans the onus was on them yep and
to produce the numbers and in addition
to that i i think
i think the void is also due to the fact
he was writing a book getting an emmy
you know all that stuff but anyway up
next